I'm at Wiechert's Earthquake Observatory
in Göttingen, Germany.
This is the oldest working seismic station,
— earthquake detector — in the world.
But there's also a more unusual bit
of scientific equipment here:
a four-ton steel ball that can be raised up
14 metres above the ground
and then dropped,
because it's a lot easier to set up
and calibrate an earthquake detector
if you can make the ground shake yourself.
- The equipment we have here
started to work in 1903,
and it's still working.
Wiechert was the one who created
the first real working seismometer.
These things record on smoked paper.
This is ordinary white paper.
We take the flame of a paraffin burner
to get soot onto that paper.
We think we are the only ones in the world
who are doing that.
Wiechert had a theory
that seismic waves allow you
to look into the inside of our planet.
His assistant, Mintrop, had to
prove Wiechert's theory.
He started to calculate, and he found out
if he takes a ball of about four tonnes
and drops it, then he is
creating a small earthquake,
an earthquake big enough
to check the theory of Emil Wiechert.
- The researchers here a century ago
could create a tiny artificial earthquake
and then measure it.
So what?
Well, earth tremors move
through the ground in two ways.
The P-waves, or primary waves,
compress the ground back and forth
in the direction that the wave is travelling,
squeezing it together.
Travelling slightly slower are the S-waves,
the secondary waves,
which shear the ground side-to-side.
And those waves behave differently,
in duration, and wavelength, and intensity,
depending on the ground
they're travelling through.
So, if you're clever,
and Mintrop was clever,
then you could set up seismic
detectors all round an area,
create a small artificial earthquake
by, say, dropping a four-ton steel ball,
and use the reflections
from within the earth
to build up a picture of what was below
without having to dig.
- This knowledge spread
all over the world.
Mintrop got an invitation to Mexico
from an oil-drilling company.
They had an oil field. They asked Mintrop
if he could measure the size of that oil field.
He said, "I don't know. We don't
have oil fields in Göttingen,"
but he accepted the invitation to Mexico,
and of course he did not
take the ball with him,
because in Mexico he was allowed
what he wasn't allowed here.
He was allowed to use dynamite.
And he measured the size of this oil field
with incredible accuracy.
He had the not-so-nice nickname
The Crazy German.
He was running around with bodyguards,
hiding his equipment in tents,
because our American friends were very eager
to find out how that works,
because that was the
licence to print money.
- So, 100 years ago, with a
much older release mechanism,
and probably a lot more effort,
that steel ball dropped for the first time
onto what was then
pretty much flat ground.
Nowadays there's much better equipment
for figuring out what's under
the earth's surface but, uh,
it's not quite as dramatic.
- I told you your camera would fall...!
- [laughter]
It's still rolling!